- [Narrator] Have you ever wondered
why children often look a little similar
but also very different from
their biological parents,
or even how biological siblings
tend to share some common features
but still have different
traits from each other?
To answer this question,
we have to go beyond the physical traits
that we see in these family portraits
and dive into genetic inheritance.
In this video,
we're going to see that
it's sexual reproduction,
a mechanism used by many
organisms to produce offspring,
that creates the diversity of traits
that exist in biological families
and in animal and plant
populations all around the world.
Let's start from the beginning.
All life comes from other life
through the process of reproduction.
Parents reproduce to form offspring,
and during this process,
they pass on their genetic
information to their offspring.
During sexual reproduction,
two parents produce offspring.
So each offspring gets a
mixture of genetic information
from two parents.
Parents pass this genetic
information to their offspring
via chromosomes, the
coiled up DNA molecules
found inside your cells
that contain genes.
Sexually reproducing organisms
often have many different chromosomes,
each containing specific genes.
For example, this diagram represents
a complete set of human chromosomes.
As we can see, there are
23 different chromosomes
assigned numbers one through 23.
However, there are two
copies of each chromosome,
so that there are 23 chromosome pairs
instead of 23 single chromosomes.
Each chromosome pair is a homologous pair,
which means that the two
chromosomes are the same size
and contain the same
genes in the same order.
However, the alleles on the
two homologous chromosomes
may be different,
meaning that the chromosomes
may not exactly have the
same genetic information.
Also, in case you're wondering,
the last chromosome set
is a little different,
because that chromosome 23
is the human sex chromosome,
which influences the biological
sex of the individual,
but we don't have to
get into that just yet.
What's important to know for our purposes
is that sexually reproducing organisms
with two sets of chromosomes
in each of their cells
are called diploid.
Diploid organisms, the
D-I, di indicating two,
have cells with two sets of chromosomes
that are organized into homologous pairs.
Sexual reproduction occurs
through a process called fertilization,
and during fertilization,
cells called gametes, which
are egg and sperm cells,
fuse to form a new organism.
Each parent contributes one gamete.
So you might be wondering,
if each of the parents'
organism cells are diploid,
and offspring result from the fusion
of cells from two parents,
how do the offspring
of sexual reproduction
maintain the same number of chromosomes?
Well, diploid organisms
form gait that are haploid,
meaning that they only contain
one set of chromosomes.
When you hear the word
haploid, you can think of half,
because haploid cells have half the amount
of genetic information
than diploid cells have.
A human haploid gamete, for example,
contains 23 single chromosomes,
one of each homologous pair.
When gametes fuse during fertilization,
that brings the total number
of chromosomes back to 46,
or 23 homologous pairs.
So why is sexual
reproduction so important?
Well, not only does it allow
organisms to produce offspring,
but it also creates genetic
variation and diversity.
The reason that offspring
have different traits
compared to their parents,
and that one sibling looks
different from another,
can be attributed to sexual reproduction.
This diagram here helps
illustrate how sexual reproduction
creates genetic variation.
The diagram shows a cross
between two hypothetical parents.
It shows the chromosomes
and the possible gametes
that the parents can form,
and the possible chromosome
combinations in the offspring.
So in the diagram,
we can see that each
possible parent gamete
contains one chromosome
from a homologous pair,
and during fertilization,
gametes from each parent fuse together,
resulting in offspring
that have a combination of
chromosomes from both parents,
and this is where the genetic variability
between parents and offspring comes from.
Offspring are not genetically
identical to either parent
because they contain a
mixture of genes from both.
The diagram also shows us that,
because each parent passes
on only one chromosome
from each homologous pair,
there are multiple
combinations of chromosomes
that can occur in the offspring.
For example, the pink
chromosome from parent one
can be paired with the dark
chromosome from parent two
in one offspring,
and the light blue
chromosome from parent two
in another offspring.
Keep in mind that this diagram
only shows the inheritance
of a single chromosome,
but in humans, this occurs
for all 23 of our chromosomes,
and as a result,
there are millions of different
chromosome combinations
that an offspring can inherit.
This is why siblings can look
alike, but aren't identical.
Even more mind blowing,
there are other genetic processes
that occur during fertilization
that increase variation even more,
resulting in trillions of
possible allele combinations
for each offspring.
This is why no two people
except monozygotic twins
are genetically alike.
To summarize, we learned that
sexual reproduction occurs
when two haploid gametes fuse
together in fertilization,
creating a diploid offspring
with homologous chromosome pairs.
We also learned that the patterns
of chromosome inheritance
during sexual reproduction
lead to genetic variation
in families and populations.
It's why children look different
from their biological
parents, brothers, or sisters.
We've all inherited
different sets of chromosomes
because of sexual reproduction,
which in turn makes each and
every one of us one of a kind.